ich würde sagen da wären wir jetzt
einfach mal geopfert ich bin sehr
gespannt ob das klappt wo mein gott
ansonsten ist schön mit dir
[Musik]
ja
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
beim ein video ja damit ich hoffe
natürlich geht's gut heute mit einem
wirklich coolen video auf das ich mich
sehr freue
ich fange einfach direkt mal an es geht
um dieses produkt wir haben hier ein
smartphone
und zwar dass die s70 ich habe dieses
handy zugeschickt bekommen und die
meinten jo schau dir das man kann es ja
mal eine meinung zu sagen
ich krieg von denen noch ein handy also
dass es 90 das gibt es aber allerdings
noch gar nicht das ist kein typisches
handy so wie man es kennt sondern mehr
so ein gaming handy
also das hat so ein paar features wie
extrem lange akku laufzeiten von drei
bis vier tagen irgendwie wir haben bei
diesem handy ein militär standard 810g
und es ist ja ip68 wasserdicht das heißt
wohl wirklich wasserdicht sowie dann
manche iphones oder manche
samsung-handys sie dann nur spritzwasser
geschützt sind wenn man da den pool geht
mit dem gerät ist plötzlich kaputt das
ist wirklich 100 prozent wasserdicht
sein
das test mama und wird es natürlich auch
was hält das alles aus also es ist
wirklich ein extrem robustes smartphone
ich habe überlegt ich könnte eigentlich
mit meinem auto drüber fahren
das ding ist das möchte ich bei diesem
hier glaub ich noch nicht so gerne
machen sondern erst bei dem was ich auch
noch zugeschickt bekommen wir also dass
es 90
was dann noch robuster ist aber gut so
viel zum anfang
ich würde sagen wir machen das direkt
mal auf und schauen wir zusammen rein
wenn man das jetzt schon hier so sieht
es ist wirklich ziemlich groß also ich
würde es ungefähr mit meinem iphone 7 +
vergleichen was ja gerade von der größe
her also leute so sieht die verpackung
aus habt ihr grad schon gesehen wir
haben wir leider noch eine
speicherkapazität von 6 gb
man kann aber auch noch eine
speicherkarte bis zu 64 gbyte hinzufügen
dann haben ein bisschen mehr wir machen
das einfach mal auf und es sieht direkt
also es hat so irgendwie was von also
ich finde von der von der verpackung her
ist es halt natürlich man erkennt dass
es ist aber irgendwie auch so eine
andere art und weise also die meisten
smartphones haben ja eine weiße
verpackung oder keine ahnung
auch wenn man das jetzt so sieht also
irgendwie wird mir das jetzt irgendwie
in die hand drücken wird sich nicht
direkt das ist ein smartphone ist so das
ist ja noch mal deutlich größer als
meine sieben plus hier steht auch direkt
noch ein paar daten drauf 12 megapixel
kamera
5 megapixel frontkamera also ich will
jetzt gar nicht so tun als hätte ich da
extrem viel ahnung von wir testen das
ist einfach mal aber mir gefällt es auf
jeden fall schon mal sehr gut jetzt
schauen wir mal rein guckt sondern wir
haben hier natürlich einen adapter
ladegerät glaube ich halt in deutschland
den rekord für android ladegeräte ich
habe mich schon so viel herum fliegen
und noch irgendein adapter das ist jetzt
allerdings das erste handy das sich aus
pappe wo keine kopfhörer dabei sind naja
also wenn man das jetzt in der hand hält
heute schaut euch mal wenn man von vorne
drauf schaut erkennt man direkt okay das
ist ein smartphone mann von hinten drauf
schaut könnte es auch irgendwie so eine
speicherplatte sein oder somit die
direkt fotos schießen kann keine ahnung
also alles ein bisschen anders als man
es kennt jemand kleiner vergleich iphone
7 und das ding wiegt ungefähr das
doppelte bis dreifache also bevor ich
das jetzt start und teste wir machen
gleich den wassertest und schmutz test
vielleicht war ich auch mit dem auto
drüber jetzt werden wir mal sehen weil
es ist wirklich also das ist schon ein
starkes ding und fallenlassen kann man
es ja auch mal ich meine ist jetzt
einfach ein test für euch und das hat
nichts damit zu tun dass ich mit handys
nicht gut umgeht man will hier an die
grenzen bringen so es geht an dorothee
powered by android finde ich immer gut
wenn man das bekommt und das nicht erst
kurz aufladen muss hat übrigens ganz
wichtig was ich noch gar nicht gesagt
hab das hat einen wert von 300 euro
kostet 299 euro auf amazon ist natürlich
jetzt nicht wenig aber wir schauen wir
ob es diese 300 euro auch wirklich wert
ist ich richte das mal kurz ein und dann
melde ich mich wieder
es sollte was ich direkt schon echt cool
finde wir haben hier einen fingerabdruck
system das heißt wir können unseren
finger drauf legen wie beim iphone
machen super gerne leute wir haben hier
auf der rückseite den sensor da legt man
den zeigefinger drauf so jetzt habe ich
schon mal direkt meine fingerabdruck
eingegeben das ding hat grad 9 80
prozent geladen kann man sich ja märkten
auch schauen wie viele es nach unseren
tests ganz typisch der touch
funktioniert mir gut schon mal direkt
auf mehr
wir schauen aber youtube reinschauen uns
mal kurz media an was ich sehe gerade so
in den trends deutschland sucht den
superstar leute schauen wir mal
man kann hier einfach so ok das geht
beim einfach nicht so weit ich weiß also
das funktioniert schon mal recht gut bin
ich begeistert war auch okay schauen uns
mal kurz doch die kamera an leute was
geht das nämlich jetzt gerade mit dem
handy auf also so ist die videoqualität
auch die fotos fand ich ganz cool mit
der frontkamera nicht ganz so die
normale kamera macht aber ein echt gutes
bild wenn ich euch natürlich hier ein
ihr könnt ja mal sagen was ihr davon
haltet an sich aber bis jetzt alles gut
so also ich glaube von der leistung her
ist man hier mit 300 euro
auf jeden fall ganz gut dabei und das
hat mich bis jetzt auf jeden fall
überzeugt ich kann jetzt natürlich auch
nicht alles testen aber es ist ja dafür
gemacht möglichst robust zu sein
möglichst wetter tauglich zu sein einen
möglichst guten akku zu haben der jetzt
übrigens schon nur noch bei 88 prozent
ist und deswegen gehen wir jetzt einfach
mal raus und check mal ab ob das auch
wirklich alles funktioniert und wirklich
so robust ist also machen alex wie handy
zerstörungs test wichtig ist dass wir
alles zu es auch das sind ja ich bin
gespannt kommt man mit
ist es mir noch bleibt runter gefallen
scheiße
also bis jetzt alles noch ganz leute
genau hier hinter uns ist ein kleiner
fluss wer ist ungefähr so 30 bis 50 cm
tief ich würde sagen da wäre es doch
einfach mal gucken jetzt ist es da drin
und jetzt muss ich irgendwie wieder raus
war alles dabei
[Musik]
also dann passiert wirklich gar nichts
natürlich ist das jetzt hier kein extrem
tiefes gewässer
man könnte es dann auch noch in tiefe
gewässer schmeißt das problem ist sich
kriegst du nicht mehr raus will mir das
jetzt es ist kalt ist will ich mir nicht
antun poveda ist allerdings vom auto
drüber fahren was zwei tonnen wiegt
haben wir noch einen anderen test
vorbereitet also außer das ist ein
bisschen dreckig wird passiert auch hier
absolut nicht so ein krasses handy hatte
ich noch nie bin wirklich begeistert
warum jetzt direkt beim autor über leute
und nochmal ganz wichtig an die die
jetzt in die kommentare schreiben
wie gehst du damit um das ist ja nur ein
test handy ich mache den test für euch
das heißt wenn ich das irgendwie von
euch kaufen möchte es ist wirklich
robust und hält vieles auch schon das
ganze ist übrigens kein facebook nicht
viel geld dafür
die haben ja einfach ein handy
zugeschickt wenn jetzt hier eine firma
seite und mir auch mein handy zu
schicken wollt könnt ihr das sehr gerne
machen dann lässt sich das allerdings
wenn meine eigene meinung genauso wie
hier obst
also leute wir haben uns jetzt hier
diese stelle ausgesucht das ding ist
hier gibt der boden so ein bisschen nach
also wir haben nicht direkt einen ganz
harten untergrund unter und ich lege
dass jetzt gleich so hierhin also mit
dem bildschirm nach oben nicht das halt
so kleine steine da rein drücken und
gefahren mit diesem auto darüber dass
wegen ungefähr so zwei tonnen
ich bin so gespannt ich bin wirklich so
weiter arbeiten weiter
ja okay also leute
ich bin so gespannt ob das klappt wo
mein gott
ansonsten
dass gar nichts passiert gar nichts
also leute ich muss sagen dass hier
nicht wirklich nicht gedacht
es ist absolut nichts passiert außer
dass es jetzt noch dreckiger ist also
das muss man sich mal vorstellen
das ist sehr heftig so haben wir es
machen noch mal kurz für sauber also
wenn man jetzt einem handy zehn von zehn
punkten geben kann dann ist das jetzt
hier mal angebracht oder oder ist das zu
optimistisch schrieb ja noch eins von
denen das soll noch robuster sein da
müssen wir uns dann irgendwie eine
steigerungen aus denken vielleicht mit
dem lkw oder so er weiß so sieht wieder
aus wie vorher eigentlich ne
ich bin wirklich begeistert genau leute
was geht
ich bin jetzt hier im schnitt wieder ob
ich fertig geschnitten ich habe noch gar
kein ende gemacht ist mir aufgefallen
fahrzeuge doch bitte mein aussehen ich
bin gerade ist aufgestanden
also hier haben wir das handy sieht
wieder aus wie neu ich habe es nur mit
shampoo gewaschen ich hab mal geschaut
das video haben wir gestern gedreht das
handy war ungefähr so ja bestimmt fünf
stunden an über den tag und es hat immer
noch 88 prozent ich habe natürlich nicht
viel mitgemacht aber es war an
und das zieht ja eigentlich auch akut
zumindest einmal den anderen handys
leute es hat mir auf jeden fall richtig
spaß gemacht das video gestern zu drehen
und ich habe mir auch die ganze zeit
schon überlegt was kann man noch machen
doch noch eine schippe drauf zu setzen
und ich glaube wir fahren da demnächst
wirklich mit dem lkw drüber oder mit
einem panzer so gar keine ahnung was ich
mal schauen muss ich mal schauen
inwiefern ich das umgesetzt bekommen
wenn ihr darauf gehabt dass man doch
nach oben da ansonsten freut euch auf
jeden fall auf das video und ich kann
nur subjektiv sagen meiner meinung nach
wirklich gutes handy für leute die viel
unterwegs sind die vielleicht ab und zu
mal den ein oder andern alkohol absturz
haben ist das ein gutes ding geht nicht
kaputt und ja mehr kann man dazu nicht
sagen das war's in dem video haut rein
wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder ciao